[Music]
i've been waiting for this moment
for a very long time
this is the one
this is the one that's going to change
everything
this is black adam
[Music]
5 000 years ago kondok was a melting pot
of cultures
wealth power and magic
yet most of us had nothing except for
the chains
around our necks conduct needed a hero
instead they got me i did what needed to
be done
and they imprisoned me for it
now five thousand years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
i have a knack for destroying bullies
but there are some who think i need help
hawkman
dr fate
and their new recruits
cyclone
and adam smasher they call themselves
the justice society
an organization that believes in
fighting for truth
and justice well i'm going to teach them
that the only beliefs i fight for are
mine
welcome to truth justice and the black
adam way
so as you guys can see we are
cooking up something pretty badass and
and certainly a lot of fun that we are
all
excited about to deliver to you guys um
and i can't wait to show you more you
know
i always thought that it might be cool
to hang out with superman
that would be cool right i mean we're
kind of similar in terms of our powers
our strengths our speeds because look at
the end of the day you never know
black adam and superman could become
friends
or they won't
who knows maybe we'll see but before i
go
i want you guys to help me out with
something it's something that's pretty
important
i need you guys to help me get a message
out to uh
to some of the other ones some of the
other dc superheroes
let's let flash shazam
aquaman wonder woman
batman and superman
let's let them know something things
will never be the same
because the hierarchy of power in the dc
universe is about to change
welcome back everyone it's charlie do
you smell what the rock is cooking this
is gonna be my black adam trailer video
i'm surprised about how much he showed
off
at dc fandom there's a bunch of easter
eggs obviously hyping up a big crossover
with the justice league and superman so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a couple other big dc movie trailers
that they dropped and they also talked
about shazam too so i will explain
what's going on with that because that's
tangentially
tied to the black adam movie even though
he and black adam aren't going to cross
over to like shazam 3 or black adam 2.
but we're doing a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you're
most hyped up to see
in the black adam movie so we'll just
start at the beginning of this talk
about the footage then talk about the
big crossovers that he was talking about
during that panel
so the footage just starts with the
introduction and his voice over talking
about how he's waited for this moment
for a long time
that's actually him speaking as dwayne
johnson the rock it's literally been
over 10 years at this point since he
started trying to get a black adam movie
going at dc and warner brothers
but as the footage kind of goes down
through this tomb here this is just
meant to be the tomb that he's been
imprisoned in for thousands of years
before
escaping in present day during the movie
they revealed the official logo of the
movie
obviously it's meant to be a twist on
the shazam movie logo because their
powers come from the same place
they also did a shazam 2 panel
separately and revealed a bunch of
details about that movie shazam 2
is actually going to be called shazam
fury of the gods
i'll talk about that a little bit more
at the end of this video after i talk
about all the black adam movie stuff
but then the trailer does the black adam
backstory starting in kondok 5 000 years
ago in the middle east
and how back then magic was a much
bigger thing publicly as opposed to
present day
when shazam the wizard other magic
characters in the dceu
largely operate from the shadows hidden
from public view
the shazam movie kind of turned that on
its head though because they did all
that on the evening news so just like
after the man of steel movie the world
was like aliens oh wow this is a big
thing we know the aliens exist now and
then justice league happens and even
more aliens come to planet earth
now magic is a much more public thing in
present day
the version of black adam's history that
they're going with in the trailer here
is the slave backstory just to make him
feel a little more sympathetic more of
an underdog
because he's going to be an anti-hero
during the movie most of the other
trailer footage in his voice over kind
of implies that
the slaves all needed a hero but instead
of a hero they got him like he never saw
himself as a hero
then they launched into a larger version
of that shazam magical powerpoint that
the wizard gave to billy about black
adam he says quote unquote i did what
needed to be done and they imprisoned me
for it so obviously he's talking about
his big battle with the council of
wizards at that time for releasing the
seven deadly sins
but the way he narrates it during the
black adam trailer implies that he did
that to help the slaves and take down
the more powerful people that were
abusing them
but you do see him fighting a much
younger version of the wizard shazam so
jaime hansu will be featured during the
movie
for this part of the backstory but i
don't know how big he's going to be
during the movie
when he says 5000 years later he escapes
you see that purple jewel
that's not supposed to be eclipso or the
heart of darkness or anything like that
i think this is just implying that black
adam was imprisoned in that purple jewel
just like the seven deadly sins were
imprisoned in this magical sphere
but he says he breaks free in present
day and you see kondok laying in ruins
around him it's been 5 000 years so
that's not a huge surprise
but then here he says that no one will
ever stop him again and it seems like
he's busted in on some warlord's throne
room
killed him and sees control of the
region again so this is obviously just
teasing the part of the story the black
adam movie will be him taking control of
kondok again
or trying to rebuild kondok in this part
of the region then you see them launch
into this big justice society part of
the trailer where it seems like hawkman
and dr fate are teaming up with him in
the middle east and present day to take
down some warlords military force
the reason why these characters are
relatively important in the dceu
to black adam is because they're also
ancient
extremely long-lived dr fate is just a
title that's passed down to each person
who wears the helmet of fate which acts
like a conduit for the cosmic magical
being naboo who's a god in his own right
and then you all know that hawkman
reincarnates so that's how he's been
alive this whole time
since the original time of black adam
thousands of years ago
the rock revealed during this panel that
they also had hawk girl
in the movie too for a little while but
for some reason they had a problem and
had to take her out he said that he'd
explain the full story behind that at
some point
but usually that happens because the
character is being used in some other
movie
then he introduces the new characters
for the justice society he calls them
their new recruits adam smasher played
by noah centennial who you remember from
a bunch of netflix stuff recently
in cyclone they didn't really say much
about her during the movie other than
seeing that she got a big costume
upgrade but noah centennial joined the
panel to explain what's going on with
his version of adam smasher during the
movie
he said that he's a brand new superhero
hot off the presses and he's not
really big on the superhero life so part
of his arc in the movie is all about
finding out what it means to be a hero
and then deciding to fully embrace life
on the justice society
then the rock makes a bunch more
references to superman movies
truth justice in the black atom way but
just in general based on a lot of this
footage it seems like a lot of the story
is going to take place
in this middle eastern region in the
world in present day
outside of the flashbacks to explain his
backstory from thousands of years ago
but then he actually goes on talking
about which other modern justice league
characters he wanted to cross over with
he talks about wonder woman just because
they have a lot in common they both come
from the world of gods and magic
but then he really really talks a lot
about fighting superman the whole joke
about how he feels like we'd really get
along
or maybe we won't wink wink i think the
reason why he's doing that is because
he's just trying to hype up this new
contract that henry cavill is supposedly
signing to cameo in a bunch of upcoming
dc movies
so punch that fight card black adam
versus superman coming 2022
but then he takes it one step further
and starts trash talking the entire
justice league like let him know put him
on notice and he even calls out shazam
and batman we always knew that he was
going to cross over with shazam and just
pound the crap out of the shazamly in
the sequels
but it's actually news to me that they
plan on crossing him over with the
justice league at some point
because that sounds like what he's
trying to hype up eventually he will
cross over with the full-blown
version of the justice league i know
there's a lot of questions about what's
going to happen with future justice
league sequels there's been a lot of
rumors out there
i think it's going to be a long time
before they try another justice league
movie
but on the other side of things with
shazam zachary levi has said that the
plan
is to eventually put shazam in the next
justice league movie so it also sounds
like the rock is also saying that black
adam would show up during the next
justice league movie 2.
when they said that the title of shazam
2 is going to be fury of the gods i
think the gods that they're referring to
are the gods the shazamly's powers are
actually based on but they also tease
the magic
lands so as you would expect the sequels
will get bigger and bigger in terms of
scope
and mythology just deepening the world
of the magic side of the dc eu
but everyone let me know in the comments
what are you most hyped up about for the
black adam movie it just sounds like
it's gonna be
super hardcore so i'm excited to see
some more footage but i'm also still
working on my flash movie teaser video
that should post in the next day or so
and there were a couple other trailers
for tv stuff that i'll try to do this
week too
and if you're a big fan of super
hardcore superhero series
the boys season 2 is premiering next
week i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes it is super hardcore
you guys have no idea if you haven't
been watching that series already
congratulations to the giveaway winner
for my dc fandom
merch giveaway rng wexton please email
me on the about page of my channel so i
can get your contact details
everyone click here to watch the batman
trailer a billion more times and click
here for the suicide squad movie trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight